everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm today we're in round three
of our coverage of the 2015 london chess
classic the first two rounds have not
been the most exciting in my opinion
there's been ten matches there's been
only one victory and that was a nice
Giri over toefl off in the first round
that we covered button round three
looking for some more fireworks
hopefully some players kind of loosen up
a little bit it's usually in these big
tournaments you expect a little bit of
slow play at the beginning and then his
players start to realize that they need
to get some wins actually win the
tournament that starts to loosen up a
little bit so that's what we're going to
be expecting in the next few rounds but
her match today White's going to be
played by the 25-year old Frenchman
Maxime about [ __ ] like a bath and his
opponents going to be played by toe claw
likes to cover to Bob just because he is
an exciting player he always has some
crazy openings and also he's in the lead
of the grand chest tore this three
tournaments he won the first one Norway
and then it did fairly well in the sink
field cop and so looking to have a
strong performance here to kind of claim
the entire crowd but he has to be
careful he lost the first round against
a nice Giri and so he can't fault her
any way the rest of the tournament
really looking for a victory here but
Maxine goes starts with pawn to e4 and
then we see the Sicilian with pawn to c5
from here Maxime continues with Knight
to f3 who's heap on here to d6 pawn to
d4 capture after the night recaptures on
d4 Knight to f6 Knight c3 and this is
kind of a turning point of what is toe
blob going to defend with there's a lot
of variations in the Sicilian defense he
opts for the night or defense one of the
stronger options out there and we see an
interesting move from the Frenchman he
plays pawn here to h3 not the most
common a move this is the Adams attack
is it's somewhat there to kind of catch
your opponent off guard night orb
defense you're really expecting you know
you have your night or your bishop here
to g5 that's pretty popular after here
you know pawn to e6 pushing up here pawn
to f4 getting ready to castle on the
queenside in an interest in an all-out
blitz blacks is going to cast on the
King side and then it's just people
going at each other's throats if we
don't see Bishop there to a g5
another one would just be Bishop here to
e3 very common you could also see the
Fisher attack with Bishop here to see
for this is what I typically play I
really like to get my life's where a
bishop involved usually going to bring
it back here to be three can always play
pawn here to a three and kind of kick it
back here on a two and this really
controlled this long light squared
diagonal here always nice especially
when black is usually going to be
playing this pawn here to e5 no pawn is
going to be blocking off this pawn chain
or this long LightSquared diagonal here
so that's always nice but we see the
atom attack here with pawn here to h3
and then pawn here to e5 and then I it's
going to come back here to e2 and this
is kind of a you know how this atom
attack goes really looking to play pawn
here to g4 later now play night to g3
behind that and then start to push
forward castle on the queenside and then
just go all-out blitz again on the King
side now with this set knowing kind of
what white wants to do we see black
respond accordingly plays pawn here to
h5 making sure that this pawn to g4
which made extremely good move if this
palm wasn't here is not allowed right
away we do see pawn here to g3 this
Bishop can't really develop out outside
of this night right here so getting
ready to be in Canada Bishop here to g2
and now we see night here to the seven
Bishop here to g2 then pond down here to
be five since this night is on here at
the seven other slideshow bishops not
going to be doing too much going this
direction so instead wants to go ahead
and start to attack on the queenside in
case his opponent does decide to castle
on the queenside you can also be in
kiddos Bishop here to be seven trying to
control this light square diagonal as
well that appear to a d5 capture and
recapture with the Queen wants to make
sure he holds on to this efore square
with his Bishop protecting and then
attacking the rook the worst going to
come there to be eight and then Bishop
here to e3 not really any other moves
want to make sure he still has this
opening for the Queen to come back but
doesn't want to make sure he develops
this Bishop in case he wants to Castle
on the queenside now [ __ ] bear to e7
getting ready to castle on the kingside
queen coming back here to a d2 night
here to f6 attacking this pawn here on
e4
and then castling on the king size was
really hoping to see castle on the
queenside a thing is completely fine we
just been a more exciting game in my
opinion not that the game is not
exciting but any time both sides are
castling on the opposite sides of the
board it's pretty much just throw
everything you can at that side of the
king it's that's what we would have seen
pawn here to be for palm pushing up
forward here to g5 and this is just kind
of a race and it would have been pretty
chaotic but we didn't see that instead
on board instead of casting on the
queenside we see castle on the kingside
so club responds with the castle on the
King side as well then we see the King
come here to h2 protecting this palm
wants to make sure that his light square
Bishop here doesn't have to hold on to
this as well also allows for the night
to come here to g1 if it wants to place
it a little bit different maybe here to
f3 later on can also do that the bishop
area to of b7 as we talked about it
really wants to control this long
LightSquared diagonal here and wants to
start attacking this pawn right here
both the night here on f6 and this
bishop here are both attacking the pond
LightSquared bishop is the only piece
defending this and so why it's going to
play night here to see three adding
another defender right here and then we
see Rick over here to see eight
attacking this night and now pawn to a4
I really don't like pawn here to a for a
black is getting ready to push forward
with pawn here to be for forcing this
night away and so I really like paneer
to a3 I think it's just a lot more solid
it stops black from doing what he wants
to do pawn here 284 I don't really think
does that so after paneer de force we
can imagine palm pushing forward here to
be for trying to remove the defender so
we have this night and this Bishop Aaron
g-tube you always want to look at the
overloaded piece and that's kind of what
this pawn here on e4 is and so if we can
kind of remove this defender this opens
up the door for these pieces to kind of
overload and take this pawn now white
really plays the only movie has and
that's to play night here to d5 kind of
stopping the bishop from attacking this
and we do see an exchange on board now
pawn here to a5 kind of solidifying this
pawn chain right here so we kind of look
on board right here we have a backward
pond here on d6 a white can definitely
look to attack that also has a backward
pawn here on a five if he can get rid of
this he has a passed pawn that he can
start to push forward on on the opposite
side of the board we see a semi-open
file for this rook here on c8 so kind of
controlling this both sides have double
bishop pairs so not a real advantage for
either side there's still a lot of ponds
on the board so a lot can go on from
this position but right now it's fairly
equal on board now we see Maxine play
Queen here to e2 wants to make sure
you're still holding on to this pawn on
c2 since it is being attacked by the
rook appear on CH Bishop down here to g5
and then we see the bishop take here on
g5 as we just talked about the Queen
can't come here to h5 because then we're
just going to see Bishop to e3 and then
after the pawn takes we're going to see
Rick come down here to see to that's
going to be very very bad for white so
instead we see the bishop just take here
on a g5 after the Queen recaptures the
pawn is going to come up here to h4
fortunately the Queen to come back the
Queen comes back here to f6 I'd rather
prefer just the Queen comin back here to
e7 to protect this fish appear on on b7
and you'll see that even more because
after the Queen comes here to f6 this
queen is going to spring into action
both attacking the bishop here on b7 and
this pawn here on a 5 and blacks forced
to play Queen here to e7 he could also
just try to protect his Bishop but his
pawns going to fall so he just kind of
wasted a move in my opinion because just
brought his Queen back here to e7 but
tow blob is is a very smart player so
I'm sure there was a reason that he
decides to go and just have this in
between moving and eventually just come
here to e7 or he could have just kind of
overlooked that but the queen is now
going to come here to 85 and now White
has a pawn that he can start pushing on
board so decides to go ahead and give up
this pawn here on c2 which I completely
agree with any time you can exchange
pawns and it come out with a passed pawn
that's definitely going to be a good
thing they were coming here to a c1 and
then rook takes here on b2 now work over
here to be one broke over here too
to the Queen captures now the bishop
comes here to a 6 attacking the rook and
the Queen comes here to be three
attacking the rook they're just going to
exchange these pieces on the board and
then all of a sudden we see Rick coming
over here to AAA so in the exchange I
feel like white definitely came out on
top he has the past pawn right here on
a4 he can just push all day long it's
going to be very difficult for black to
kind of hold on to this not the biggest
advantage but definitely a better pawn
structure than kind of black ass he
doesn't have tons of material that he
can really back I started as he pushing
this forward and he still has this pawn
here I have two that's stopping this
pawn here from just pushing freely up
the board piling up here to a five
anytime you have a passport to make sure
you push it so that's what Maxine is
doing pawn here to e4 work up here to be
three just making sure that it kind of
stops it doesn't want this pond to go
any further upon here to f5 just
solidifying the pawn chain right here
and then queen over here to do d to I
think Queen to d2 is a pretty bad move
you know I get it wants to make sure
that he has more pieces over here
stopping any sort of threat that black
has and protecting the pun over here on
a five but it's just way more dangerous
to play pawn here to a six it's really
stop it's really tough for like to stop
this you know pawn here to F we're
trying to blow things up but then work
up here to be seven you always want to
get your rook on your opponent's
seventh-ranked if you're white
second-ranked if you're black this is
very tough all the pawn canal come here
to a seven white has to you know our
black has to deal with this the entire
game so very very difficult I just don't
think that's just playing the Queen here
to d2 is as strong as just pushing the
pond but that's still okay still has a
passed pawn but now it's just kind of
under fire the Queen's now attacking it
the rook is attacking it and now Quinn
over here to a b2 decides I'm gonna go
ahead and give up that pond for a strong
attack on the King side and so after the
rook takes here on a five I would have
preferred the Queen take it just because
rook here to be seven is very tough we
we saw before any time you get your work
on the seventh-ranked this is going to
be good kind of forcing black to kind of
make a move here and then getting this
Queen involved to this King's pretty
safe over here on g2 I just feel like it
would have been better Queen taking here
on a five getting that passed pawn all
of a sudden black is up a pawn in
material and he's not super worried yet
even if the rook were to come here to be
seven or anything like that but aside to
go ahead and take with his rook other
word comes up here to be seven rook down
here both attacking the Queen's that's
fine the Queen just comes up here to be
five and then Topalov plays very very
questionable move I haven't seen a move
this bad in a long time in a big
tournament he plays rook takes here on
f2 and the Kings just going to take and
i'm not sure if he may be thought he saw
a three-fold repetition because he knew
the king was going to take and so he
knew who's going to bring his Queen down
here but the problem is it's pretty easy
to defend this you just play Queen here
to e2 you're never going to be able to
get past this and all of a sudden you're
down a rook and material until blob
after this was forced to resign he
recognized that he made a blunder but
it's not he didn't really say why he
decided to go ahead and take their my
guess is he miscalculated and thought
that he had a three-fold repetition
where he could just check check check
there was nothing that I could do and
they would just have a drawn game
because he didn't like his position so
in the first three rounds topalov has
lost two of his matches so not going
well for him kind of opens up the door
for everyone that was a ranked behind
him for the grand chest tour but
congratulations to the 25 year old
Frenchman Maxime really well played
against such a top player wit and you
don't see the atom attack you know all
that often so always good to see someone
attack the night or defense and come out
with a win so hopefully you guys are
enjoying the tournament this round was
more exciting than round two in my
opinion around one definitely the match
that we looked at was was pretty
entertaining as well so excited for more
chess over the next week and I'll see
you guys in the next video thanks for
watching